hello and welcome i'm james murphy from
m coding and today we're talking about
storing passwords
and how hashing salting and peppering
your passwords
can improve your security before we get
started if you're interested in password
security there's a good chance you'd
like your own website
and if so check out this video's sponsor
hostinger
host a website for just 139 a month with
the single shared hosting plan
or for just 259 a month host up to 100
websites with the premium shared hosting
plan
which comes with a free domain use code
m coding at checkout for up to 91
off claim your free domain and don't
forget to secure it with https
all right let's talk about database
leaks whether it be from a sql injection
attack
a misconfigured server or a disgruntled
employee
database leaks are bound to happen from
time to time
not necessarily to your company but to
some companies
so let's go through a hypothetical
database leak and see what happens
if plain text passwords are leaked
versus hash passwords
versus salted hashed passwords versus
peppered salted hashed passwords each of
these things
provides a different extra level of
security that the previous did not
all right let's get started with plain
text passwords it's the simplest case
and it provides the least security for
obvious reasons
updating a password in plain text just
involves taking the password from the
user
storing it in some kind of user object
and then sending that to the database to
you know update the record verifying it
is just
comparing the inputted password against
the stored one in the database
and one thing you can do is to use a
compare digest which is a constant time
compare
to avoid things like timing attacks
although if you're storing passwords at
all
you've already messed up in main here
i've just got a dummy database class
that prints things out about the user
when you call the store method our users
are just going to be a data class with
an email and a password
and i'll simulate updating the password
for a user and then verifying the
correct and
an incorrect password in the event of a
database leak
this is obviously the worst case the
hacker gets every user's email
and password in plain text that means
that they can use that email and
password to log in as any user
for this service or they could try using
those credentials to log into
other services so if a hacker gets your
facebook password
they may just try to log into your bank
account with that same information
of course you're supposed to use a
unique strong password for every service
that you use
but who actually does that let's see how
we can improve the situation by
incorporating a hash function
in this version we take in a hash
function and instead of storing the raw
password
we store the hash version of the
password we additionally stored the name
of the hash function that we used
so that in the future if we ever want to
migrate to a different hash function
we can tell which function was used to
hash the password
verifying the password then just comes
down to looking up the hash function
that we used
and then hashing the password with the
given hash function
and comparing against the one we have
stored it's also important to note here
that for all of these examples
i'm actually doing some base64 encoding
this is very common in practice
and it makes it a lot easier to read
when we print things out it's not super
important but i do also want to note
that the dollar sign is not used in
base64 encoding
that makes it safe to use as a separator
for the name and hash
and that's why we can just split the
password like this to recover those
things
okay so let's get to taking a look at
what the hacker sees
when a database of hashed passwords is
leaked
so here's what the hacker would see if
hashed passwords were leaked
they can't see the passwords directly so
they do have to do at least some work
but they can recognize and break common
passwords because these hashes
could be precomputed they can also guess
passwords offline for those that aren't
precomputed
since they know which hash function was
used this is a big win
since the server won't ban them for too
many wrong attempts potentially allowing
them to break weak passwords
even if they haven't been pre-computed
also if they are able to crack a
password that multiple users have used
it cracks the password for everyone that
used that password all at once
they can also see if any two people have
the same password
since those two passwords would have the
same hash even if the hacker isn't able
to identify what the password is
from this data this is a lot better
situation than plain text passwords
being leaked but
at this point you should probably assume
that any one of your users that had a
weak password is compromised
so how can we improve this by using
salts
well what is assault anyway assault is
just a little bit of extra randomness
that we sprinkle in with the user's
password
assault should be unique for each user
you can see here that instead of just
hashing the password directly
we hash the salt together with the
password
then when we store the password we
actually stored the name
the salt and the hashed password when we
verify we recover the salt from the
user's stored password
and then use that together with the
inputted password
hash it and use that to compare against
the hashed password that was stored for
the user
so here's what the hacker sees when
salted hash passwords are leaked
of course they can identify the hashing
algorithm that's used
and because we put the salt in there
they also get the salt out
of course then there's the hash but if
the salt is right there
what's the purpose of using it the
hacker just gets it for free
well the big win here is that hackers
can no longer recognize
hashes of weak passwords because
throwing those salts in there made them
all unique
precomputed hashes become effectively
worthless
a hacker can still guess passwords
offline and check to see if they're
correct
since the salt is known that was part of
the information that was leaked in the
database
this allows them to potentially break
weak passwords
but if the hacker does spend the time to
crack
a weak password it only cracks it for
that one person it doesn't crack it for
everyone that shared the same password
they also can no longer tell if two
people have the same password by looking
at the hash
okay then what's a pepper and how does
it differ from assault
well a pepper is similar to a salt in
that it's some randomness that you
sprinkle in with the password
but its primary difference is that a
pepper is specifically something that
you do not store in the database
assault was stored in the database with
the password but a pepper
is stored somewhere else it's stored
perhaps in your application code
or in a secure memory enclave because
it's not stored in the database
it's something that a hacker doesn't see
even if the database is leaked
additionally it's typical to only have
one pepper for your entire application
since we can't store the pepper in the
database it wouldn't make sense to have
one for each user because where would we
store that information
the way that you use a pepper though is
pretty similar to the way that you use a
salt
you just sprinkle it in with the salt
and the password at hash time
and then when you want to look it up you
still get the salt from the hashed
password that was stored in the database
but you get the pepper from wherever you
get it stored in some secure memory
enclave
so what does using a pepper in addition
to the salt and hashing by us
well the hacker can still see the hash
function and the salt
but the pepper isn't there because it
wasn't stored in the database the hacker
doesn't even know a pepper is involved
and because the hacker doesn't know the
pepper they can no longer guess weak
passwords offline
the hacker would need to simultaneously
leak the database
and the application code to get any
useful information out of the database
leak
at which point it would be similar to
the situation where we were just using
hashed and salted passwords
the only downside to using a pepper is
that since no database is used
it may be harder to ensure that every
server has access
to this pepper because of these benefits
i think the peppers are going to start
picking up a lot more steam in the
future
but currently most libraries don't
support peppers but they do support
salts
i'd like to see that start to change in
the future but right now that's just how
it is
because you really shouldn't be writing
your own authentication systems you
should just be
using open source well proven ones this
probably means that you won't be able to
use peppers in the near future
because they don't support it yet but i
will at least link to a best practices
document so that you can at least see
what you should be doing in the modern
day and how you should be storing
passwords securely
using the tools and projects and
libraries that are available to us
right now so that's all i've got on
hashing salting and peppering your
passwords i hope you learned a little
bit
if you enjoyed the video please don't
forget to subscribe
leave a like leave a comment it really
helps out with the algorithm
see you next time